tyler mcgill getting ready for his third
big league start his second at citi
field he has acquitted himself quite
nicely so far that's hoping to get him a
little deeper into the game
tonight after going four in a third and
five in his first two starts the 0-1 on
the way and urea swings and lines it to
shortcut reaching up to his shoulders by
lindor
and mcgill goes off speed and strikes
him out with the change-up beautifully
done by mcgill to get yellidge for the
second half
and this one in the left field the base
hit all the way down the line and adamus
will try it in the second base and hold
with a two out double two out uprising
for the brewers it's up to tyrone taylor
two and two the count to taylor now the
pitch and it's in there strike three
called so mcgill slips a fastball over
for a call strike three and they'll
oppose brandon woodruff the brewer
all-star
yeah brandon has won his last two starts
he beat the cubs his last time out of
american family field six indies four
hits one run
and boys he excelled in each season in
his progression infield pop taken by
peterson for the first down here's the
pitch swinging to bouncer hit towards
first kira gloves it flips to woodruff a
little bit behind him but woody's able
to get the bag
and a swing and a miss and woodruff
wins the battle
the swing and a miss and he throws
fastballs by hira
he pulls that one on the ground could be
too mcneal
to vr and on to first in time for the
double play
four five three on the double play and
the mets turn two behind mcgill
woodruff ready in his 2-2 to alonso
fastball strike three called inside
corner at the knees
and a slow roller
for the second out
[Music]
and a slow roller rate for woodruff and
he puts it
over to first for the final out here in
the second inning of all two strikes
gill out of the wind up his pitch
swinging a missed strike three high
fastball takes care of woodruff louisia
lined out to short to open the game and
he hits this one sharp leland door to
his left sweeps it up
and makes the play for the second out
nicely done by lindor going to his left
2-2 coming and yelling chases the change
up again and mcgill gets him for the
second time
one-two pitch swing and a miss
got vr swinging with a curve ball
and he called strike three another
strikeout for brandon woodruff
here's the o2 and he called strike three
mcgill didn't want anything to do with
brandon woodward there
chopped on the ground one long hop for a
vr
and mcgill retires adamus who has the
only hit here's omar narvaez he was hit
by a pitch back in the first
and this one hit to right all the way
back
and gone
scoreless no more
as narvaez goes deep for his eighth home
run and the brewers grab the early lead
it's one to nothing they were just
talking about how good the changeup has
been while he hung one outer half and
norvaya is able to barrel it up and
knock it out of the ballpark
which would be understandable punch the
other way by nimble that's a fair ball
and the mets have their first base in it
caroms off the tarp and nemo in easily
at second base brewers bring their
infield in batter now is dominic smith
pitch
smith it's a high fly ball right center
field plenty deep enough to get the run
home bradley to his left angles in makes
the catch coming home from third is
nimmo the throw on the way to the plate
not in time nimmo scores standing up
he's hurt right now and mcgill strikes
out here on a fastball for the second
time
certainly worked for him last night
popped up behind third out goes vr and
comes smith don calling all the way
nicely done by dom he has a much better
angle
and he chops one down toward third so
you hit it to the left side right the r
throws him outside retired i gotta
retire
grounded into the shift
for the first out
this one hit a long way center field but
jackie bradley junior's there
bouncer hit to the first baseman kesten
hero fields on two hops feeds brandon
woodruff and it's another one two three
inning
for woody the mets manufacturing a run
as smith drove home a run on a sacrifice
fly against brandon woodruff here's the
o2
called strike three woodruff got the
benefit
of the outer edge there's mccann barks
back
and so he is
stuck so far
and this one granted
and a nice job by woodruff to make sure
he covers first base and never did slow
down 1-1
nemo ground ball hit to short adamus has
it flips to first and plenty of time to
get nimo and that ends the inning only
64 pitches through six innings for
brandon woodruff who started the night
with a 1.87 era and is only better that
3-1 coming and lendura takes inside ball
four in the midst of a lead off base
runner first walk of the night for
woodruff tom smith at the plate has been
the men's honest tenor over the last
week
and he swings and hits one up the middle
base hit
lindor around second he'll go on to
third um smith finds the middle of the
diamond and the mets at their second hit
of the night here in the bottom of the
seventh inning game tied at one alonzo's
do up
and pete lines went down the line of the
mets will take the lead
lindor is in smith digging for third
gary desarcina is going to wave him home
dumb heads for the plate he'll score
ahead of the throw by adramus it's a
two-run double for pete alonso and the
mets rated three to one on the seventh
mitch leading three to one and michael
conforto's the batter pitch
swinging aligned right base hit in the
right field from michael conforto alonso
scores and the mets have put up three
here in the seventh against brandon
woodruff it's a four to one mitch lead
as conforto drives in his 16th of the
year and the mets in great position now
to break this game open
ground ball the third chance for two
here for milwaukee and they get the
double play what a job
this place is jumping because edwin diaz
has entered the game the trumpets
blaring thus the brewers have the first
two men on in the ninth now we'll get
the tying run to bat
and this one base hit left field the
wave the runner home and the brewers
now within four to two
three two coming
struck him out
he went to the slider it was right in
the middle of the plate and peterson
missed it and that's the first down in
the night and now kesten hiro who struck
out swinging all three times
struck him out two men down brewers are
down to their final out of the night
first pitch swinging a high fly ball
shallow left could be playable polar
near the line with room makes the catch
put it in the box
the new york mets hold on diaz works out
some rust
and the mets have taken the opener